So Fox News Smurf reporter Peter Doocy tried
to do a gotcha yesterday with Joe Biden's press
secretary, Jen Psaki. It failed so miserably that
I don't know how he can respectably show his face
in the press briefing room again. And to be
clear, he will show his face there again. He has
no shame, but he should be ashamed. And it seems
like it's a trend among the modern right there,
unable to be embarrassed by their self
humiliating behavior. The issue is once again
Major League Baseball, which has quickly become
the top issue for Fox News. They've moved on,
I guess, from Dr. Seuss. And
the new game they are playing
is arguing it's silly for Major League Baseball
to move the All-Star Game from Georgia to Colorado
because Colorado has the same voting laws that
they are protesting in Georgia. Now, let me be
crystal clear. If it were true that Colorado had
the same voter laws as Georgia, it would look
pretty stupid for Major League Baseball to say
we're protesting the Georgia voting law by moving
the game to a state with the exact same law. That
would be really stupid. There's no doubt it's not
the case, though. And Jen Psaki knows it. And this
goes really poorly for Steve Doocy. Take a look.
Is the White House concerned that
Major League Baseball is moving their
All-Star game to Colorado, where voting
regulations are very similar to Georgia?
Well, let me just refute the refute the first
point you made. First, let me say on Colorado,
Colorado allows you to register on Election
Day. Colorado has voting by mail where they
send to 100 percent of people in the state who are
eligible applications to vote by mail. Ninety four
percent of people in Colorado voted by mail in the
2020 election. And they also allow for a range of
materials to provide, even if they vote on
Election Day for the limited number of people who
who vote on Election Day. I think it's
important to remember the context here. The
Georgia legislation is built on a lie. It's there
was no widespread fraud in the 2010 election.
Georgia's top Republican election officials
have acknowledged that repeatedly in interviews.
And what there was, however, was record
setting turnout, especially by voters of color.
So instead, what we're seeing here is for
politicians who didn't like the outcome,
they're not changing their policies to win more
votes. They're changing the rules to exclude
more voters. And we certainly see
the circumstances as different.
But ultimately, sorry, let me add one more thing.
It's up to Major League Baseball to determine
where they're holding their All-Star game.
So Jen Psaki was ready. And it's actually an
even sillier comparison between Georgia and
Colorado than Jen Psaki makes it out to be.
It's not at all serious to consider the voting
circumstances and laws in the two states. The
right is saying, well, Colorado also has voter
ID. They do. But Colorado's voter ID is what's
called a non strict voter ID law. It's not the
obvious and outrageous voter suppression attempt
that the Georgia law is in Colorado. Voters
can produce a number of different types of ID,
including ones without photos. If you don't
have ID, you can still vote by provisional
ballot. And at that point, election officials
are charged with verifying eligibility,
Georgias in person ID requirement is what's called
a strict law. It must be a voter ID, a photo ID.
If you don't have one, you can cast a provisional
ballot, but you then still have to bring a photo
ID within three days. Dramatically different
circumstances. But here's the more important
issue. The Georgia voter ID law. At issue is for
mail in voting. Why are they even talking about
the in-person voter ID when this is all about mail
in voter ID? Now next issue. But but but David,
hold on. Colorado and Georgia both have similar
numbers of days for early in-person voting.
That's true. But Colorado elections are almost
done completely by mail. Early in-person voting
isn't particularly necessary nor relevant in
Colorado because almost everybody votes by
mail. All registered voters automatically get
an absentee ballot somewhere between ninety
and ninety nine percent, depending on elections
of voters use the mail and voting option. So,
yes, Colorado has roughly the same number
of in-person early voting days as Georgia.
But given how few people use that option, given
how accessible mail and voting is in Colorado,
it's incontrovertibly easier to vote in Colorado.
So in total, Colorado is widely considered a
strong state for voter enfranchisement, for making
it easier for people to vote. Georgia's new bill
is a beacon of disenfranchisement. And then just
the last thing on this, I do think it's important
to understand the motivations of the recent
Georgia bill because the comparison about the
rules is a fair one to make. And as we just
did, the rules clearly are more favorable
to enfranchisement in Colorado. But the Georgia
bill came from too many Democrats voting in 2020,
Joe Biden winning Georgia and 20 20 Democrats
unseating two incumbent Republican senators in
Georgia in 2020. That's the motivation for
Republicans. But we Republicans didn't see
Biden win. And two Democrats defeat two incumbent
Republicans in Georgia and say, let's pass a bill
to make it easier for more people to vote. No,
of course not. Their strategy all along was to
suppress the vote. This is why Trump opposed
mail in voting. They saw they didn't suppress
enough of the vote to win. And so now they're
trying to suppress more of it and we shouldn't
ignore it. We shouldn't be naive and only
look at the rules and ignore the motivations,
the motivations. A big part of it as well. And
another complete and abject failure by Peter Doocy
to catch Jen Psaki in these very flaccid gotcha
question attempts. Let me know your reaction
about all of it, about the laws in Georgia and
Colorado, about produces continued attempts to
make Jen Psaki look bad. Whatever your thoughts
are, you can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We're going to take a quick break. And
we have so much more to discuss today.